[Música]
[Aplausos]
en estos minutos quiero hablarles de
todas las adversidades y los desafíos
que tuve que enfrentar en mi vida
y en mi trabajo para lograr lo que
soñaba estos desafíos y estas
adversidades realmente me han
fortalecido para lograr lo que yo quería
en todo y así respetando mi propia
esencia
pude escribir mi propia historia
cuando yo era chiquita jugaba a que
conducía programas para chicos
así como la escuchan armen era muy
chiquita ven aquí hace muchos años
jugaba a conducir un programa infantil
como lo hice
bueno agarré el trípode el secador de
pelo de mi mamá le puse una caja de
cartón
y vieron el rollo de papel higiénico
bueno eso era mi lente lo puse ahí y a
través de excelente yo creía que estaba
conduciendo un programa presentaba
dibujitos cantaba bailaba
qué increíble no
de chica jugaba a lo que en el futuro se
convertiría en mi vocación en mi
profesión y en mi trabajo
yo estaba sola en casa mi mamá trabajaba
todo el día
soy hija única de padres separados
única hija de padres separados en todo
el colegio o sea que no fue fácil
tuve muchas carencias hostilidades
me críe diferente eran otras épocas
y yo frente a eso creo que de alguna
manera incorpore a lo que me motivó y me
y me hizo destacar después fue mi motor
seguramente porque mis padres se
separaron de una manera no buena fue
durísimo yo quedé ahí en el medio tenía
cinco años
madure de golpe
sentí el abandono de mi papá la ausencia
y eso yo creo que fue como un gran
motivador como algo detonante fue como
una gran fortaleza que me dio porque
quise revertirlo en el futuro por eso a
los 8 años yo ya jugaba a lo que a lo
que iba a ser mi familia porque yo
conducción brava para chicos en familia
no tenían idea de esto o sea nadie nadie
hacía esto es más yo tenía todo en
contra porque en esa época no estaba
bien visto ser actriz
nadie aspiraba a esto nadie quería estar
en la televisión estaba muy mal visto y
ellos lo veían como un entretenimiento
como un juego yo arranque de cero
literal
pero peso cero contactos cero
pero sabiendo que quería
escribir una historia distinta diferente
quería destacar me tenía como esa
necesidad de destacar me en algo
diferente en algo especial dije cómo voy
a entrar a la tele bueno me anoté en una
agencia de modelos no iba ni podría ser
modelo obviamente mi game 1 metro 59
imposible pero bueno esa era la manera
que yo entendía en este momento que
podía entrar a la televisión que podía
lograr entrar de alguna manera al otro
día me llamaron para un casting de una
película bueno yo estaba en quinto año
tenía 17 años fuimos con mamá ella me
acompañó llegué última al casting última
significa que era hasta las 6 de la
tarde yo llegué el seis menos cuarto ese
día me enteré que buscaban
a la chica hacía tres meses
habían pasado por todos los talleres de
teatro
y recurrieron a una agencia de modelos
yo casi no voy
pero fuese menos mal así que bueno yo
fui al casting como les dije y ahí me
dijeron qué
se trataba de la filmación de la
película de evita
evita era el año 83 era julio del 83
estaban los militares
todavía
era algo que no se sabía evitar a un
personaje completamente desconocido para
mí
jamás la había visto ni en fotos ni en
televisión ni él ni el colegio porque
estaba prohibido estudiarla estaba
prohibido decir su nombre o sea no había
internet como hay ahora no había manera
de informarte como ustedes tienen ahora
era muy diferente esto y además había
una dictadura o sea había un riesgo al
filmar esa película
pero yo estaba cumpliendo mi sueño claro
así que era ese momento
era algo muy pero muy especial
suena el teléfono yo siempre digo que la
carrera de actriz o esta carrera en la
carrera del milagro
porque un día suena el teléfono y
alguien te llame te cambia la vida y te
proponen algo que realmente te cambia la
vida pero también tienes que saber qué
puede no sonar el teléfono
y también tienes que estar preparado
para eso
porque también te puede pasar quiero
decirles que sonó el teléfono y me
eligieron para evitar obviamente esto ya
lo saben pero bueno quiero contar lo que
sonó el teléfono de vuelta y me
confirmaron que yo era la elegida para
ser la protagonista de la primer
película evita del mundo
cumplía realmente con mi gran sueño así
que bueno ahí estaba con mis 17 años en
todas las revistas en todas las tapas en
los diarios yo me creía enorme enorme
grande grande pero grande de verdad yo
creía que ya era una persona y mi mamá
vieron cómo son las madres que tienen lo
mejor para sus hijos y que me dijo bueno
todo muy lindo pero vos tenés que tener
una carrera seria así que tienes que
entrar a la uba y estudiar derecho
le hice caso por supuesto entre a la uva
a derecho al año me ofrecieron una
novela en televisión y le dije mamá
esto no es para mí y yo quiero estar en
la televisión y ser actriz me planté
tenía 18 años
eran otras épocas y le dije no y me
planteé y arriesgue
pero volviendo un poco a evita al
estreno que realmente yo sé lo que es
pasar de ser anónima a ser tremendamente
conocida
estrena la película en esta semana en
abril del 84
viene el momento de hacer la tapa de la
revista más importante de ese momento
imagínense yo estaba feliz hicimos una
producción de fotos todo el día una nota
espectacular
llegó el momento de hacer la etapa de ir
al estudio a la editorial y ahí poner
algo que
digamos por decirlo era un vestido ella
más lo que destapaba que lo que tapaba
les quiero decir obviamente estaba
demasiado provocativa
y ahí me planté y dije no no
no lo quiero hacer no quise plantarse
frente a un editorial importante dije no
no no quiero o quería y bueno en ese
momento yo tenía el cine en mis manos
podía hacer todas las películas decían
los mejores personajes de los profesores
ofrecían a mí pero claro la mayoría
todos tenían desnudos porque era ese
momento uno sabe a veces las cosas que
quieren la vida y las que no y hay que
respetarse uno sabe lo dije no no quiero
cuando uno tiene o no se planta uno no
tiene una decisión y uno tiene un no
sabemos que arriesgas
y que eso viene una consecuencia y uno
es responsable de esa consecuencia y uno
tiene que hacer cargo
iván carcela porque está bien porque por
algo uno dice que no no es capricho
porque eso tiene que ver con el
convencimiento con la convicción que
tenemos que llevar adelante en la vida
así que bueno ahí
dije bueno está que habremos llegado
usted qué les parece yo iba a dejarlo
así no por supuesto que no
y volví a empezar
volví a mi niñez
quizás lo que jugaba de chica no
entonces quise escribir mi primer
programa para chicos tenía 19 años
era muy chiquita no
escribí el programa infantil y primer
programa till como ya había trabajado en
canal 11 dije bueno pido una reunión con
el director artístico algo insólito para
esa época bueno nadie me recibe con mi
proyecto lo presentó entonces me dice
oye chica si tú eres tan caraduras en
venir a presentar este proyecto tan
ambicioso pues va a ser una gran
conductora de televisión pero nosotros
ya tenemos la 'ola verde' no nos
interesa más que esto
bueno agarro me voy con mi proyecto bajo
el brazo
y al poco tiempo la chica que conducía
la ola renuncio se acordó de mí
y me llamaron
por supuesto automáticamente acepte
acepte tenemos que entender que muchas
veces en nuestro camino se nos presentan
oportunidades que no son las que
nosotros realmente más deseamos pero hay
que darse cuenta que son la punta de un
comienzo de algo que nosotros lo podemos
direccionar hacia lo que queremos hacer
así es el lugar que realmente soñamos y
ahí va a funcionar entonces acepté bueno
ustedes algunos lo han visto seguramente
la ola está de fiesta
tanto suceso clave está de fiesta y
claro un suceso increíble
cuál fue porque no porque era distinto
porque fue diferente bueno yo tenía 19
años era muy cercana a los chicos yo no
podía hacer ni la maestra ni la mamá
podría ser su hermana mayor
entonces
soy estable sí
algo con ellos en forma directa
hablándole a pares
rompí el vídeo de la televisión
ya que es digamos todo lo ceremoniosos
que tenía en ese momento con
autenticidad con fuerza con con alegría
con con otros otra forma de hablar
qué lindo
a los productores no les gustaba eso no
querían querían seguir con el mismo
estilo de antes
pero tuve la bendición de que ustedes me
entendieron enseguida
y ustedes
me dieron el lugar
porque se convierte en un éxito
enseguida porque ustedes entendieron
que era algo que iba directo a ustedes
porque yo quería que ustedes entren en
la tele que ustedes jueguen conmigo
poder disfrutar juntos de esto
y
yo lo hice igual recuerdo cuando el
señor televisor
me presento ese día y dijo chicos tengo
una nueva amiguita para presentarles
se llama flavia
ya hizo / y dije hola chicos
y ahí quedó para siempre para siempre en
mi corazón y en el de ustedes también
realmente
adiós hecho muchas veces como dice acá
toque el cielo con las manos pero sin
despegar los pies sobre la tierra
siempre me sentía una mujer ordinaria
con un trabajo extraordinario
vencí todas las adversidades que se me
presentaron todos los obstáculos
vencí los mandatos los prejuicios de la
gente el qué dirán
y para adelante
y acá estamos y me doy cuenta que sigue
habiendo adversidades
y me sigo llenando de inseguridades
igual
sigo teniendo rechazos sigo teniendo nos
pero todos ellos me desafían el doble
como lo hicieron desde el primer día
al igual que pasó en ese momento porque
es el momento de aceptarme de quererme
d con mis propias herramientas como los
super del primer día tratar de lograr
salir adelante ustedes tienen que ser
conscientes de sus limitaciones pero
también de esas herramientas que tenemos
que nos hacen auténticos que nos hacen
originales que nos hacen únicos y que
nos llevan a ser los protagonistas de
nuestra propia historia eso es lo que
tenemos que lograr
saben que yo
qué voy a hacer ahora voy a seguir
eligiendo volver a empezar
porque es así porque de eso se trata la
vida yo recuerdo que una vez le pregunté
al director de la película por qué me
había elegido
imagínense que la persona que me cambió
la vida uno le da curiosidad
por qué
él me dijo bueno eras muy parecida
tenías una cara que transmitía lo que yo
necesitaba para la película eras la
persona que yo quería para transmitir lo
que era esa película
era buena actriz
pero hubo algo
qué pasó qué fue lo que para mí fue muy
motivador
bueno
vos viniste a hablar con nosotros en el
momento de la preselección
y vos guardas 17 años una niña te
sentaste frente a nosotros
al director a los productores y tu mamá
atrás
fuiste la única que hizo eso
esto para nosotros fue muy motivador
porque nos dimos cuenta que vos
realmente querías este papel pues
realmente quería ser su oportunidad y le
play vas a defender y vas a bancar horas
de filmación te vas a bancar a los
medios realmente te vas a ser
responsable de este personaje y de esta
gran película
y para nosotros fue algo muy
condicionante qué cosa no cuando uno va
a buscar
cumplir tus sueños a ustedes les habrá
pasado que te elijan para un trabajo
muchas veces uno dice dios mío y a veces
es un detalle pero ese detalle tiene que
ver con la autenticidad tiene que ver lo
que vos en el fondo lo que decías
realmente tiene mucho que ver no le
tengan miedo a eso no le tengan miedo a
mostrar lo que realmente quieren a lo
que realmente desean porque el
convencimiento
es lo que va a lograr que ustedes puedan
y lograr realmente sus objetivos
todo lo demás es cuestión de tiempo y de
verdad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]